ยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ความเข้าใจเรื่องข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ ฉันชื่อ John Watrous และเป็นผู้อำนวยการฝ่ายเทคนิคด้านการศึกษาที่ IBM
Quantum นี่คือบทเรียนที่ 16 และบทเรียนสุดท้ายของซีรีส์ และหัวข้อของบทเรียนคือ fault tolerant quantum
computing ตลอดสามบทเรียนก่อนหน้า เราเห็นตัวอย่างหลายอย่างของ quantum error correcting codes ที่สามารถตรวจจับและให้เราแก้ไข
quantum errors ตราบเท่าที่ไม่มีมากเกินไป ถ้าเราต้องการใช้ error correction สำหรับ quantum computing ยังมีอีกหลาย
ประเด็นที่ต้องรับมือ รวมถึงความจริงที่ว่า quantum gates, การวัด และการเตรียม state
ของเราเองก็น่าจะไม่สมบูรณ์แบบ ดังนั้น ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเราจะทำ error correction บน
qubit หนึ่งหรือมากกว่าที่ถูกเข้ารหัสโดยใช้ quantum error correcting code เราก็ต้องทำสิ่งนั้นด้วย gates และการวัดที่ตัวมันเอง
มีโอกาสทำงานไม่ถูกต้อง และนั่นหมายถึงไม่เพียงแค่ล้มเหลวในการตรวจจับหรือแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาด แต่อาจ
นำเข้าข้อผิดพลาดใหม่ด้วย นอกจากนี้เราต้องทำการคำนวณที่สนใจด้วย gates ที่ไม่
สมบูรณ์แบบ และเราไม่สามารถเสี่ยงถอดรหัสข้อมูลควอนตัมเพื่อทำการคำนวณแล้ว
เข้ารหัสใหม่เมื่อเสร็จแล้ว เพราะข้อผิดพลาดอาจโจมตีเมื่อการปกป้องของ quantum error correcting code ไม่มี
ซึ่งหมายความว่าเราต้องหาวิธีทำ quantum gates โดยตรงบน logical qubits ที่ไม่เคย
ขาดการปกป้องของ quantum error correcting code สิ่งนี้เป็นงานหนัก แต่เป็นที่รู้กันว่าตราบเท่าที่ระดับของ noise
ต่ำกว่า threshold value ที่แน่นอน จริงๆ แล้วเป็นไปได้ที่จะทำการคำนวณควอนตัมขนาดใหญ่ตามที่ต้องการได้อย่างน่าเชื่อถือโดยใช้ hardware ที่มีสัญญาณรบกวน อย่างน้อย
ในทางทฤษฎี และเราจะพูดถึงข้อเท็จจริงที่สำคัญมากนี้ในภายหลังในบทเรียน นี่คือภาพรวมสั้นๆ ของ
บทเรียน เราจะเริ่มด้วย model พื้นฐานสำหรับ fault tolerant quantum computing รวมถึงการพูดถึงสั้นๆ
ของ noise models พร้อมกับ methodology ทั่วไปสำหรับการนำ quantum circuit ไปใช้แบบ fault
tolerant จากนั้นเราจะไปยังประเด็นของการแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดใน fault tolerant quantum circuits และวิธี
ควบคุมมัน โดยเฉพาะฉันจะพูดถึงการใช้ transversal gate ซึ่งเสนอวิธีง่ายมากในการควบคุมการแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาด
แม้ว่าจะมีข้อจำกัดพื้นฐานที่ป้องกันไม่ให้เราใช้วิธีนี้
แต่เพียงอย่างเดียว ฉันจะพูดถึง methodology ต่างๆ ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ magic states ซึ่งเสนอเส้นทางอื่นในการควบคุมการแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาด
ใน fault tolerant quantum circuits แม้ว่าจะไม่ใช่วิธีเดียวที่รู้จัก และสุดท้ายบทเรียน
จบด้วยการพูดถึงในระดับสูงของ threshold theorem ซึ่งฉันพาดพิงไปเมื่อครู่
theorem นี้ระบุว่า quantum circuits ขนาดใหญ่ตามต้องการสามารถนำมาใช้ได้อย่างน่าเชื่อถือตราบเท่าที่ error rate ของส่วนประกอบทั้งหมด
ที่เกี่ยวข้องต่ำกว่า threshold value จำกัดที่แน่นอน โดยทั่วไป threshold value นี้
ขึ้นอยู่กับ error correcting code ที่เราใช้ รวมถึงตัวเลือกเฉพาะที่เราทำสำหรับการนำ fault
tolerant ของ quantum gates และการวัดมาใช้ แต่ไม่ขึ้นอยู่กับขนาดของ circuit ที่กำลังนำมาใช้ และสิ่งนี้ให้เหตุผลดีที่จะเชื่อว่า
การคำนวณควอนตัมขนาดใหญ่จะเป็นความจริงในสักวัน เราจะเริ่มด้วยการพูดถึง model พื้นฐานสำหรับ fault tolerant quantum
computing ซึ่งโดยธรรมชาติอิงจาก quantum circuits และ quantum error correcting codes เพื่อประโยชน์ในการพูดถึงนี้
ลองจินตนาการว่าเรามี quantum circuit ที่เราหวังจะนำมาใช้ เช่น อันที่แสดงที่นี่ สิ่งนี้บังเอิญเป็น
teleportation circuit รวมถึงการเตรียม EBIT แต่รายละเอียดไม่สำคัญสำหรับการพูดถึงนี้จริงๆ และคุณสามารถจินตนาการว่า
นี่คือ quantum circuit ใดก็ได้ อาจเป็น circuit ที่ใหญ่กว่ามากที่รวมถึงการเตรียม state, unitary
operations และการวัด Circuit นี้แน่นอนแสดงถึงอุดมคติ และการนำมาใช้จริง
จะไม่สมบูรณ์แบบ คำถามที่เป็นธรรมชาติที่ต้องถามคืออะไรอาจผิดพลาดได้บ้าง
มีหลายอย่างที่อาจผิดพลาดได้ ตัวอย่างเช่น การเริ่มต้น state โดยทั่วไปจะไม่
สมบูรณ์แบบ แน่นอน unitary gates จะไม่สมบูรณ์แบบและการวัดก็เช่นกัน
และยิ่งไปกว่านั้น qubit เองก็จะเสี่ยงต่อ noise รวมถึง decoherence ในทุกจุดใน
การคำนวณ แม้แต่เมื่อไม่มีอะไรเกิดขึ้นกับ qubit เหล่านี้และพวกมันแค่กำลังเก็บข้อมูลควอนตัม พูดอีกอย่างก็คือ
เกือบทุกอย่างอาจผิดพลาดได้ มีข้อยกเว้นหนึ่งอย่างไรก็ตาม หรืออย่างน้อยนั่นเป็นสมมติฐานทั่วไปและ
นั่นก็คือการคำนวณแบบคลาสสิกใดๆ ที่เกี่ยวข้องก็น่าจะไม่มีข้อผิดพลาด เพราะสำหรับทุกเจตนาและ
วัตถุประสงค์ การคำนวณแบบคลาสสิกนั้นสมบูรณ์แบบ ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเราใช้อัลกอริทึม matching แบบคลาสสิกเพื่อ
คำนวณการแก้ไขสำหรับ surface code errors เราไม่ต้องกังวลว่าการคำนวณแบบคลาสสิกนี้อาจมีข้อบกพร่อง แต่สิ่งที่เกี่ยวข้องโดยตรงกับ
ข้อมูลควอนตัมอาจเป็นได้ แน่นอนเราต้องการ model ที่แม่นยำเพื่อเชื่อมโยง
ความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับสิ่งต่างๆ ที่ผิดพลาด และถ้าต้องการเราสามารถคิด model ที่ซับซ้อนเท่าที่ต้องการเพื่อหวังว่าจะสะท้อน
สิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นจริงในความเป็นจริง ถ้า model ซับซ้อนเกินไปอย่างไรก็ตาม มันอาจกลายเป็นยากหรือเป็นไปไม่ได้ในการทำงานด้วยหรือพูดถึง
สิ่งที่น่าสนใจ ตัวอย่างหนึ่งง่ายๆ ของ noise model ที่คนมักพิจารณา
คือ independent stochastic noise model ที่ข้อผิดพลาดหรือ faults ที่ส่งผลต่อส่วนประกอบต่างกันในช่วงเวลาต่างกัน
หรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง ตำแหน่งต่างกันใน circuit นั้นเป็นอิสระต่อกัน
ตัวอย่างเช่น เราอาจพูดว่าทุก gate ล้มเหลวด้วยความน่าจะเป็นที่แน่นอน ว่า bit flips และ phase flips เกิดขึ้นกับ qubit ที่เก็บไว้ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
ต่างกันต่อหน่วยเวลา เป็นต้น แต่สมมติฐานคือไม่มีความสัมพันธ์ระหว่าง
ข้อผิดพลาดต่างๆ ตอนนี้คุณอาจคัดค้าน model นั้นเพราะน่าจะมีความสัมพันธ์บางอย่างระหว่าง
ข้อผิดพลาด ตัวอย่างเช่น น่าจะมีโอกาสเล็กน้อยของข้อผิดพลาดร้ายแรงที่ทำลาย qubit ทั้งหมดพร้อมกัน
หรืออาจน่าจะมากกว่า อาจมีข้อผิดพลาดที่อยู่ในพื้นที่แต่ส่งผลต่อส่วนประกอบหลายตัว
และไม่มีใครโต้แย้งอย่างอื่น แต่อย่างไรก็ตาม model นี้แสดงถึง baseline ง่ายๆ ที่
โดยพื้นฐานแสดงถึงแนวคิดว่าธรรมชาตินั้นคาดเดาไม่ได้ แต่ไม่ได้ประสงค์ร้ายและไม่ได้พยายาม
จงใจทำลายการคำนวณควอนตัม มี noise models อื่นๆ ที่ถือว่าสมจริงกว่าที่มักพิจารณากัน และโดยไม่คำนึงถึง
model ที่เราเลือก ถ้าปรากฏว่า model ของเรานำเราหลงทางและเราเรียนรู้สิ่งใหม่เกี่ยวกับข้อผิดพลาดใน
ระบบที่เรากำลังทำงาน เราก็สามารถกำหนดและพิจารณา error models ต่างๆ ได้อย่างเป็นธรรมชาติ ต่อไปเราจะ
ดูกลยุทธ์พื้นฐานสำหรับการนำ quantum circuits มาใช้แบบ fault tolerant ดังนั้นลองพิจารณา
logical quantum circuit ที่กำหนด ซึ่งหมายถึง quantum circuit ในอุดมคติที่เราสนใจรัน ตัวอย่างเช่น เราสามารถพิจารณา circuit เดิม
ก่อน ซึ่งตอนนี้ยืดออกเล็กน้อยเพราะเราต้องการพื้นที่เพิ่มขึ้นเล็กน้อยสำหรับการนำ fault tolerant มาใช้ ก่อน
อย่างแรก การเตรียม state, unitary gates และการวัดจะไม่ถูกทำโดยตรงเป็น single gates หรือเป็น
single qubit measurements หรือการเตรียม state แต่จะถูกทำโดยสิ่งที่เรียกว่า gadgets ซึ่ง
แต่ละตัวอาจเกี่ยวข้อง qubit หลายตัวและการดำเนินการหลายอย่าง ที่นี่ใน diagram นี้ฉัน
แสดงสิ่งนี้โดยวาดกล่องสีม่วงรอบสิ่งเหล่านี้ และคุณสามารถคิดถึงกล่องสีม่วงเหล่านี้เหมือน circuits หรือการดำเนินการขนาดเล็กที่
มีป้ายกำกับตามการเตรียม state หรือ gate ที่เราตั้งใจนำมาใช้ ประการที่สอง เราต้องปกป้อง
qubit โดยใช้ error correcting code ดังนั้นจะไม่ใช่ logical qubits เองที่เชื่อมต่อ gadgets เหล่านี้ต่างๆ แต่ gadgets กระทำบน
physical qubits ที่เข้ารหัส logical qubits เหล่านี้ และสมควรที่จะเน้นที่นี่ว่า logical qubits ที่เราสนใจ
ไม่เคยถูกเปิดเผย ซึ่งหมายถึง logical qubits เหล่านี้จะใช้ชีวิตทั้งหมดของพวกมันถูกปกป้องโดย
quantum error correcting code ใดก็ตามที่เราใช้ และสุดท้าย เราทำ error correction บน qubit ที่เข้ารหัส
ซ้ำๆ ตลอดการคำนวณ โดยพื้นฐานแล้วทุกครั้งที่เรามีโอกาส และสิ่งสำคัญที่เราต้องทำ
คือสิ่งนี้ ในแง่ intuitive เมื่อข้อผิดพลาดเกิดขึ้น ความสุ่มหรือความไม่แน่นอนเริ่มสะสมใน state ของ
qubit และเราต้องทำงานอย่างต่อเนื่องเพื่อกำจัดความสุ่มหรือ entropy นี้ และสิ่งนี้เกิดขึ้นผ่าน error correction
ดังนั้นคุณสามารถคิดถึงขั้นตอน error correction เหล่านี้เหมือนตู้เย็นขนาดเล็กหรือ heat pumps ที่
ช่วยให้ logical qubits คงความเย็นเพื่อให้การคำนวณทำงานได้ถูกต้อง
เมื่อตัดสินใจทั้งหมดเหล่านี้แล้ว ซึ่งหมายถึงการเลือก gadgets ทั้งหมดรวมถึงโค้ดและสมมติ noise model เฉพาะ มีคำถาม
พื้นฐานที่เราสามารถถามตัวเองได้ นั่นคือสิ่งนี้ช่วยได้จริงไหม เรากำลังทำให้สิ่งต่างๆ ดีขึ้นหรือ
แย่ลงกันแน่ ถ้ามี noise มากเกินไป เราอาจทำให้สิ่งต่างๆ แย่ลงได้
เหมือนกับที่ 9 qubit Shore code ทำให้สิ่งต่างๆ แย่ลงถ้าโอกาสข้อผิดพลาดสูงเกินไป
แต่ถ้า noise ต่ำกว่า threshold ที่แน่นอน งานพิเศษทั้งหมดนี้จะนำเราไปสู่บางแห่ง และอย่างที่เราจะพูดถึงในตอนท้ายของบทเรียน
เส้นทางเปิดขึ้นสำหรับการลด error ต่อไป ในส่วนนี้ของบทเรียน เราจะพูดถึงการแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดใน fault
tolerant quantum circuits ที่มีโครงสร้างพื้นฐานที่ฉันเพิ่งอธิบาย สิ่งนี้ปรากฏว่าเป็น
ความกังวลหลัก เพราะถ้าเราจัดการการแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดไม่ดี ข้อผิดพลาดจะครอบงำความพยายาม error
correction ของเราอย่างรวดเร็ว แต่ถ้าเราสามารถควบคุมการแพร่กระจายของข้อผิดพลาดได้ โค้ดของเราก็จะมีโอกาสที่ดีขึ้นมาก
ในการตามทัน เพื่อให้ข้อผิดพลาดสามารถแก้ไขได้ในอัตราที่สูงพอเพื่อให้การคำนวณของเรา
ทำงานได้ จุดเริ่มต้นสำหรับการพูดถึงนี้คือการตระหนักว่า two qubit gates หรือ multiple qubit gates โดยทั่วไป
สามารถแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดได้แม้เมื่อพวกมันทำงานถูกต้อง
ตัวอย่างเช่น พิจารณา CNOT gate และสมมติว่า X error เกิดขึ้นบน control qubit ก่อน CNOT gate
ถูกทำ X error ทำงานเหมือน X gate และเราพบว่า
circuit ทางซ้ายเทียบเท่ากับ circuit ทางขวาที่ X errors เกิดขึ้นบนทั้งสอง qubit หลัง CNOT
นี่คือการแพร่กระจายของข้อผิดพลาด เพราะตำแหน่งที่ไม่โชคดีของ X error ทางซ้ายทำให้มันกลายเป็น
X errors สองตัวทางขวาอย่างมีประสิทธิผล และเราจะไม่หลีกเลี่ยงสิ่งนี้ได้ ตราบเท่าที่เราใช้ CNOT gates ก็จะมีโอกาสเสมอที่
X error เกิดขึ้นบน control qubit ก่อนมัน ซึ่งแพร่กระจายไปเป็น X errors สองตัว
หลังจากนั้น แต่อย่างที่เราจะเห็น ตราบเท่าที่เราดำเนินการเพื่อจำกัดความเสียหายที่เกิดขึ้นนี้ เราก็โอเค และโดยวิธี
ปรากฏการณ์เดียวกันเกิดขึ้นเมื่อเรามี Z error บน target qubit ก่อน CNOT และเราพูดถึงเรื่องนี้
แล้ว และคุณสามารถตรวจสอบความเท่าเทียมเหล่านี้ได้โดยทำการคูณหรือตรวจสอบโดยใช้
Qiskit สรุปคือในทั้งสองกรณีนี้จะทำให้เกิดข้อผิดพลาดที่มีความสัมพันธ์กันบน qubit หลายตัว และแน่นอน
เราไม่ควรลืมว่า CNOT gates เองก็อาจมีข้อบกพร่องซึ่งอาจทำให้เกิดข้อผิดพลาดที่มีความสัมพันธ์กัน
ด้วย เพิ่มความกังวล subsequent two qubit gates อาจแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดเหล่านี้ไปอีก
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเรามี CNOT gates สามตัวแบบนี้ เหมือนกับที่เราพบเมื่อวัด X stabilizer generators เช่น ข้อผิดพลาดเดียวสามารถ
แพร่กระจายไปยัง qubit หลายตัวอย่างรวดเร็ว และถ้าสิ่งนี้เกิดขึ้นภายใน code block เดียว เช่น กลุ่มของ
qubit ที่เข้ารหัส logical qubit ร่วมกัน error correcting code ที่เราเลือกก็จะไม่มีโอกาส
เพราะโค้ดถูกออกแบบเพื่อแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาด low-weight ไม่ใช่ข้อผิดพลาด high-weight แบบนี้
ดังนั้นนี่คือสิ่งที่เราต้องคำนึงถึงอย่างจริงจังขณะที่เราคิดเกี่ยวกับ gadgets และ
ขั้นตอน error correction ใน fault tolerant quantum circuits วิธีง่ายที่สุดที่รู้จักในการบรรเทาการแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดใน fault
tolerant quantum circuits คือการนำ gates มาใช้แบบ transversal และฉันจะอธิบายว่าหมายความว่าอะไร
ในอีกสักครู่ ดังนั้นมาดูรูปของการนำ fault tolerant circuit ไปใช้บนหน้าจอเพียงเป็นสื่อช่วยมองเห็น
แนวคิดที่นี่คือสำหรับ quantum error correcting codes บางตัว gates บางอย่างสามารถนำมาใช้แบบ transversal ซึ่ง
หมายถึงการนำมาใช้โดยใช้ gadgets ที่เป็น tensor products ของการดำเนินการที่แต่ละการดำเนินการกระทำเพียงบน
ตำแหน่ง qubit เดียวภายในแต่ละ code block นี่ง่ายที่สุดในการอธิบายผ่านตัวอย่าง อันดับแรกและ
อาจเป็นตัวอย่างที่เรียบง่ายที่สุดคือการนำ Pauli gates ไปใช้แบบ transversal
แนวคิดคือเราต้องการสร้าง gadgets สำหรับแต่ละ gate ใน circuit ของเรา และในทุกกรณี gadgets เหล่านั้น
กระทำบน code blocks เหมือนที่เราเห็นสำหรับ X และ Z gates ตอนท้ายของ teleportation circuit ของเรา แน่นอนเรา
ไม่สามารถถอดรหัส apply Pauli gate แล้วเข้ารหัสใหม่ เพราะนั่นจะทำให้ logical qubit ไม่ได้รับการปกป้องและข้อผิดพลาด
อาจแพร่กระจายภายใน code block เป็นผลจากการเข้ารหัสใหม่
โชคดีที่เราไม่ต้องทำเช่นนั้นตราบเท่าที่เราใช้ stabilizer code เพราะ stabilizer code ทุกตัวช่วยให้ Pauli
operations สามารถ apply ได้โดยตรงกับ logical qubits ของเรา และจริงๆ แล้วเราทำสิ่งนั้นได้ด้วย tensor product ของ Pauli gates
บน physical qubits ที่ใช้สำหรับการเข้ารหัส
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเราพิจารณา 3x3 surface code ที่เกิดขึ้นตอนท้ายบทเรียนก่อน เราสามารถนำ X และ Z gates ไปใช้บน logical
qubit ที่เข้ารหัสโดยโค้ดนี้ได้โดย tensor X และ Z gates เข้าด้วยกันพร้อมกับ identity gates ในรูปแบบที่
แนะนำที่นี่ นี่คือการนำ transversal มาใช้ของ gates เหล่านี้เพราะทุกหนึ่งของการดำเนินการ gate แต่ละตัว
เหล่านี้กระทำเพียงบนตำแหน่ง qubit เดียวภายในแต่ละ code block
เราใช้แค่ single qubit gates ที่นี่ ดังนั้นมันค่อนข้าง trivial ในแง่หนึ่ง แต่อย่างไรก็ตาม gadgets แบบนี้จะไม่ทำให้ข้อผิดพลาด
แพร่กระจาย ตอนนี้ gate แต่ละตัวใน gadget แบบนี้อาจล้มเหลว และนั่นจะนำเข้า
ข้อผิดพลาด แต่จะทำ error correction ทันทีหลัง gadget ทุกอัน และตราบเท่าที่ error rate
ต่ำพอ error correcting code จะแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดเหล่านั้น
และอย่างที่ฉันบอก สิ่งนี้เป็นไปได้เสมอสำหรับ Pauli gates สำหรับ stabilizer code ทุกตัว
แม้ว่าคุณต้องระบุรูปแบบที่ถูกต้องของ Pauli gates ใน gadgets เพื่อนำ Pauli operation แบบ logical ที่ต้องการไปใช้ได้อย่างถูกต้อง
สำหรับตัวอย่างอื่นที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ two qubit gates ครั้งนี้เราพิจารณาการนำ transversal
ของ CNOT gates มาใช้ โดยเฉพาะสำหรับ CSS code ทุกตัว เราสามารถนำ CNOT gate ไปใช้เสมอ
ระหว่าง logical qubits สองตัวได้โดยเพียงแค่ทำ CNOT gates บนคู่ที่สอดคล้องกันของ physical
qubits และนี่ตรงตามเงื่อนไขของการเป็น transversal เพราะ CNOT gates แต่ละตัวเหล่านี้กระทำเพียงบน
ตำแหน่ง qubit เดียวภายในแต่ละ code block ตัวอย่างเช่น CNOT gate แรกกระทำเพียงบน qubit บนสุด
ภายในแต่ละ code block CNOT gates ที่สองกระทำเพียงบน qubit ที่สองจากบนสุด เป็นต้น
ในกรณีนี้อาจมีการแพร่กระจายของข้อผิดพลาดเพราะ CNOT gates แพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดและไม่มี
วิธีป้องกันสิ่งนั้น แต่กุญแจสำคัญคือการแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดไม่เคยเกิดขึ้นภายใน code block เดียว ตัวอย่างเช่น
X error อาจเกิดขึ้นบน qubit บนสุดของ code block บนสุดก่อน gadget ถูกทำ และ CNOT แรก
ภายใน gadget จะแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดนั้นไปยัง qubit บนสุดใน block ล่าง แต่สองข้อผิดพลาดที่เกิดขึ้นนั้น
ตอนนี้อยู่ใน code blocks แยกกัน ดังนั้นขั้นตอน error correction ที่เกิดขึ้นหลัง gadget จะสามารถแก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดเหล่านั้นได้แต่ละตัวเพราะ
ข้อผิดพลาดเหล่านั้นส่งผลต่อ qubit เดียวภายในแต่ละ code block เท่านั้น
ในทางกลับกัน ถ้าการแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดเกิดขึ้นภายใน code block เดียวกัน เราอาจเกิดปัญหาเพราะ
การแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดกำลังเปลี่ยน low-weight error เป็น higher-weight error ที่โค้ดของเราอาจไม่สามารถรับมือได้
การนำมาใช้นี้ไม่ทำงานสำหรับ non-CSS codes แต่ตราบเท่าที่เราใช้ CSS code เราสามารถนำ CNOT
gates มาใช้แบบ transversal ในลักษณะนี้เสมอ และสำหรับอีกตัวอย่างหนึ่ง ทุก
Clifford gate สามารถนำมาใช้แบบ transversal สำหรับ Steane code และจริงๆ แล้วสำหรับ color code ใดๆ ซึ่งเป็นหนึ่งในสิ่งที่ดีจริงๆ เกี่ยวกับ color
codes โดยเฉพาะ Hadamard gate บน logical qubit สามารถนำมาใช้ได้โดยทำ Hadamard gates แต่ละตัวบน
physical qubits แต่ละตัว และ logical S gate สามารถนำมาใช้ไม่ใช่โดย S gate บนแต่ละ qubit แต่โดย
S dagger gate บน physical qubit แต่ละตัว ดังนั้นสรุปได้ว่าการนำ transversal gate มาใช้นั้น fault tolerant โดยธรรมชาติ
เพราะไม่เคยแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดภายใน code block เดียว ซึ่งให้โอกาสขั้นตอน error correction สู้กลับ
กับข้อผิดพลาดที่นำเข้าหรือแพร่กระจายโดย gates ที่ใช้สำหรับ gadgets เหล่านี้ ดังนั้นนั่นดีและเป็น
วิธีง่ายมากในการสร้าง fault tolerant gadgets และมีโค้ดต่างๆ ที่ช่วยให้สามารถนำ transversal มาใช้กับ gates ต่างๆ เช่น
T gates แต่น่าเสียดายที่เป็นไปไม่ได้สำหรับโค้ดที่ไม่ trivial ใดๆ ที่จะนำ
universal set ของ gates มาใช้แบบ transversal ซึ่งเป็นข้อเท็จจริงที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ Eastin-Knill theorem ในรูปแบบเทคนิคที่มากขึ้น สิ่งที่มันบอก
คือตราบเท่าที่โค้ดของเรามีระยะทางอย่างน้อยสอง ชุดของ gates ที่สามารถนำมาใช้แบบ transversal จะต้องสร้างชุด
การดำเนินการที่ไม่ต่อเนื่องจนถึง global phase และดังนั้นชุดนี้ไม่ใช่ universal เพราะ universal gate
sets จำเป็นต้องสร้างการดำเนินการอนันต์ ฉันจะไม่อธิบาย proof ของ theorem นี้ซึ่งใช้ข้อเท็จจริงพื้นฐานบางอย่าง
เกี่ยวกับ Lie groups และ Lie algebras ซึ่งไม่ใช่ prerequisites สำหรับซีรีส์นี้ แต่แนวคิดพื้นฐานคือ
infinite families ของ transversal operations ไม่สามารถเก็บเราอยู่ใน code space ได้เพราะความแตกต่างเล็กน้อย
ใน transversal operations ถูก approximate ได้ดีโดย low-weight Pauli operations ซึ่งโค้ดตรวจจับว่าเป็น
ข้อผิดพลาด ดังนั้นเรายินดีมากเมื่อสามารถนำ gates มาใช้แบบ transversal แต่สำหรับโค้ดที่เราเลือก เรารู้ว่าเรา
จะมี gates บางอย่างเสมอที่เราไม่สามารถนำมาใช้แบบนี้ได้ ดังนั้นเราต้องมองหา gadgets ทางเลือก โดย
Eastin-Knill theorem เรารู้ว่าเป็นไปไม่ได้ที่จะนำ universal set ของ quantum gates มาใช้แบบ transversal แม้แต่
สำหรับ distance 2 quantum error correcting code ที่เล็กน้อย ดังนั้นเราต้องหาวิธีอื่นในการนำ gates ไปใช้แบบ fault
tolerant อย่างน้อยสำหรับบาง gates วิธีที่รู้จักกันดีวิธีหนึ่งในการทำสิ่งนี้คือผ่านการใช้สิ่งที่เรียกว่า magic
states เพื่อวัตถุประสงค์ของการพูดถึงนี้ มาระลึกถึง S และ T gates ซึ่งเป็น
single qubit gates ที่กำหนดตามที่แสดงที่นี่บนหน้าจอ มาสังเกตด้วยว่าก่อนอื่น S เป็น Clifford operation
ซึ่งมาจาก definition ของ Clifford operations ของเรา แต่คุณยังสามารถตรวจสอบว่าการ conjugate Pauli matrix โดย S เสมอให้เราบวกหรือลบ Pauli
matrix อื่น และประการที่สอง T ไม่ใช่ Clifford operation และจริงๆ แล้ว ถ้าเรารวม T กับ Hadamard และ CNOT ทั้งคู่
เป็น Clifford operations เราได้ universal set ของ quantum gates ดังนั้นเราไม่สามารถนำ T gate ไปใช้
โดยใช้แค่ Clifford operations และการวัด standard basis เท่านั้น แต่จริงๆ แล้วเราสามารถนำ T gate มาใช้ได้โดยใช้
Clifford operations และการวัด standard basis ถ้าเพิ่มเติมจากนั้น เรามี copy ของ state ที่แสดงที่นี่บน
หน้าจอ ซึ่งคือ T gate ที่ apply กับ plus state
state นี้เรียกว่า magic state แม้ว่ามันไม่ unique ในแง่นั้น
คำว่า magic state ยังใช้เพื่ออ้างถึง states ต่างๆ ที่มีบทบาทคล้ายกับอันนี้ในรูปแบบต่างๆ ของ
scheme ทั้งหมดนี้ ตัวอย่างเช่น circuit ที่แสดงที่นี่ทำงาน และไม่ยากเกินไปที่จะตรวจสอบ
นี่คือ initial state ที่มีระบบบนทางขวา และถ้าเรา apply CNOT gate และลดความซับซ้อน เราได้
state ที่แสดงที่นี่
ดังนั้นถ้าเราวัด qubit ล่างและได้ศูนย์ ซึ่งเกิดขึ้นด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2 เราไม่ทำ
S gate และ output คือ T applied to s
และถ้าเราวัดได้หนึ่งซึ่งก็เกิดขึ้นด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2 แน่นอน เราก็ apply S gate และผลลัพธ์สุทธิคือ
output ก็คือ T applied to s อีกครั้ง นี่ไม่ใช่วิธีเดียวที่จะทำสิ่งนี้ โดยวิธี มี circuits ที่คล้ายกันอื่นๆ
ที่ทำงานได้แบบเดียวกัน แต่นี่เป็นวิธีหนึ่ง
นี่คือตัวอย่างที่ simplified เล็กน้อยของสิ่งที่เรียกว่า quantum gate teleportation ซึ่งฉันพาดพิงไว้ใน lesson 4 ที่ teleportation ถูกใช้
ไม่ใช่เพื่อส่ง qubits แต่เพื่อ apply gates การเชื่อมต่อกับ teleportation อาจไม่ชัดเจนทั้งหมดที่นี่ เพราะอย่างที่ฉัน
บอก นี่คือ version ที่ simplified ซึ่งเราสามารถใช้ได้เพราะ T เป็น diagonal แต่ถ้าสนใจ
เรียนรู้เพิ่มเติม keywords คือ quantum gate teleportation
และเราสามารถทำสิ่งที่คล้ายกันเพื่อนำ S gate ไปใช้ ที่ครั้งนี้ gates เดียวที่เราต้องการคือ CNOT gate และ Z gate พร้อมกับการวัด
ซึ่งเป็นประโยชน์ถ้าเราไม่มีการนำ transversal ของ S gate ดังนั้นนั่นน่าสนใจ แต่ยัง
ไม่ชัดเจนทั้งหมดว่าสิ่งนี้ช่วยได้จริง ในกรณีของการนำ T gate ไปใช้ เช่น เรา
กำลัง apply T gate กับ input state แต่เพื่อทำสิ่งนั้น ดูเหมือนเราต้อง apply T gate กับ plus state เพื่อได้
magic state และสถานการณ์คล้ายกันสำหรับการนำ S gate ไปใช้ ประเด็นคือเรา
ไม่จำเป็นต้องสร้าง plus state แล้ว apply T gate เพื่อได้ magic state ก่อน มีวิธีอื่นที่เป็นไปได้ในการได้ state นี้ และใน
ความเป็นจริง เราสามารถทำสิ่งนี้ได้โดยไม่ต้องกังวลเกี่ยวกับการแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดในการคำนวณที่เรากำลังทำอยู่ เพราะ magic states สามารถสร้างได้
แยกต่างหาก สิ่งนี้ช่วยให้สามารถนำ T gate ไปใช้แบบ fault tolerant ได้อย่างที่ฉันจะอธิบายสั้นๆ
ก่อนอื่น เราจะไม่รัน circuit สองตัว qubit ง่ายๆ ที่แสดงที่นี่จริงๆ แต่แทนที่เราจะรัน circuit นี้โดยใช้
qubits ที่เข้ารหัสใน error correcting code ใดก็ตามที่เราใช้สำหรับการนำ fault tolerant ไปใช้ ซึ่งหมายความว่า
unitary gates และการวัดถูกทำโดย fault tolerant gadgets และนั่นหมายความว่าเราต้องการ
magic states ที่เข้ารหัสด้วย ดังนั้นทุกอย่างจะเป็น fault tolerant ตราบเท่าที่เราสามารถหา
encoded magic states ได้ เราสมมติที่นี่โดยวิธีว่าเรามี fault tolerant gadget สำหรับ S gate แล้ว ถ้า
เราใช้ Steane code เช่น เราสามารถนำ S gate ไปใช้แบบ transversal ง่ายๆ ได้ และสำหรับโค้ดที่ทำแบบนั้นไม่ได้ ตัวเลือกหนึ่งคือ
ใช้ scheme ทั้งหมดนี้เพื่อนำ S gate ไปใช้แบบ fault tolerant ก่อนแล้วใช้การนำมาใช้นั้นที่นี่
แม้ว่าจะไม่ใช่ตัวเลือกเดียว แต่อย่างไรก็ตาม กลับมาที่การนำมาใช้ คำถามสำคัญที่เหลืออยู่คือเราหา
encoded magic state ได้อย่างไร โดยที่เรายังไม่มีการนำ fault tolerant ของ T gate เพื่อทำ
สิ่งนั้นง่ายๆ และแนวคิดสำคัญคือเราสามารถใช้กระบวนการแบบ probabilistic ในการสร้าง encoded magic states และถ้ามัน
ไม่ work out ก็โอเค เราแค่ทิ้งความพยายามที่ล้มเหลวและลองอีกครั้ง
และสิ่งนั้นไม่รบกวนการคำนวณที่เรากำลังพยายามทำจริงๆ เพราะการสร้าง magic states ทำ
แยกต่างหาก วิธีทั่วไปที่ทำสิ่งนี้คือผ่านกระบวนการที่เรียกว่า magic state distillation และมันทำงาน
ดังนี้ เรามี circuit ที่แน่นอนที่เรียกว่า distiller เราป้อน distiller นี้ด้วย noisy magic
states จำนวนหนึ่งแล้ววัด output ทั้งหมดยกเว้นหนึ่ง และถ้าเรา condition บน measurement outcomes ทั้งหมดเป็นศูนย์
สิ่งที่ออกมาคือ magic state ที่มีสัญญาณรบกวนน้อยลง ซึ่งสามารถเป็น qubit หนึ่งที่ป้อนเข้า
distiller อื่น และกระบวนการดำเนินต่อจนกว่าเราจะล้มเหลวเพราะ measurement outcome ตัวหนึ่งไม่ใช่ศูนย์และเราลองอีกครั้ง หรือเรามี magic
state ที่มีคุณภาพสูงพอที่เราสามารถใช้ได้อย่างปลอดภัยเพื่อนำ T gate ไปใช้ในการคำนวณที่เราสนใจ
มีวิธีต่างๆ ที่รู้จักในการสร้าง distiller แบบนี้ แต่ทั้งหมดทำงานในลักษณะเดียวกันโดยพื้นฐาน ซึ่งคือมันเป็น decoders สำหรับ stabilizer codes
ซึ่งหมายความว่ามันเป็น inverses ของ encoding circuits ซึ่งดีเพราะหมายความว่า distiller สามารถเป็น Clifford
operation และสุดท้าย กระบวนการ distillation นี้จริงๆ แล้วเกิดขึ้นที่ระดับ logical qubit ดังนั้นในความเป็นจริง มัน
ทำโดยใช้ gadgets สำหรับ distiller และการวัด กระบวนการนี้ต้องเริ่มต้นที่ไหนสักแห่ง แต่ตราบเท่าที่ noise rate ไม่สูงเกินไป มันเป็นไปได้ที่จะสร้าง
magic states ที่มีสัญญาณรบกวนแต่ดีพอเพื่อเริ่มต้น ตัวอย่างเช่น โดยการ apply T gate จริงที่มี noise ไปยัง qubit ใน plus state และ
จากนั้นเข้ารหัส qubit นั้น ดังนั้นนั่นเป็นคำอธิบายในระดับสูงมาก แต่หวังว่าฉันให้ความคิดคร่าวๆ ว่าสิ่งนี้ทำงานอย่างไร
มันซับซ้อนกว่าการนำ gates มาใช้แบบ transversal มาก แต่อย่างไรก็ตาม มันเสนอวิธีในการนำ universal set ของ quantum
gates ไปใช้แบบ fault tolerant ในขณะที่การนำ transversal gate ไปใช้เพียงอย่างเดียวทำไม่ได้ มีบางครั้งที่อ้าง
ว่า overhead สำหรับการใช้ magic states เพื่อนำ gates ไปใช้แบบ fault tolerant ตามแนวทางเหล่านี้จะสูงมาก
ที่งานส่วนใหญ่ไปที่การ distill magic states และการรันการคำนวณจริงๆ เป็นเรื่องรอง
แต่นั่นไม่ชัดเจนจริงๆ และมีการวิเคราะห์อย่างละเอียดที่เปิดเผยว่าวิธีนี้
จริงๆ แล้วอาจ practical ได้ มีหลาย schemes ที่รู้จักสำหรับการนำ gates มาใช้แบบ fault tolerant อยู่ Code deformation และ code switching เป็นชื่อ
ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ schemes บางอย่างเหล่านี้ และวิธีใหม่ยังคงถูกพัฒนาและปรับปรุงอยู่ แต่ฉันจะไม่อธิบาย
methods เหล่านั้นในบทเรียนนี้ มีประเด็นสำคัญอีกอย่างหนึ่งเกี่ยวกับการนำ fault tolerant ของ quantum circuits ไปใช้และ
มันเกี่ยวกับขั้นตอน error correction เอง ดังนั้นนี่ไม่ใช่เรื่องเกี่ยวกับการนำ gates ไปใช้ มันเกี่ยวกับการทำ
error correction จริงๆ ปัญหาคือถ้าเราคิดถึง circuits ง่ายๆ ที่เรา
เห็นครั้งแรกใน lesson 14 สำหรับการวัด stabilizer generators ตาม phase estimation เราพบว่าพวกมันไม่ใช่
fault tolerant ด้วยตัวเองเพราะอาจทำให้ข้อผิดพลาดแพร่กระจายภายใน code block เดียวได้
สิ่งนี้ย้อนกลับไปที่แนวคิดว่าสิ่งใดที่เกี่ยวข้องกับข้อมูลควอนตัมเสี่ยงต่อข้อผิดพลาด และนั่นรวมถึง circuits ที่ตั้งใจจะ
แก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดเองด้วย สิ่งนี้ดูเป็นปัญหามาก แต่จริงๆ แล้วมีหลายทางแก้ไขที่รู้จักสำหรับปัญหานี้ ฉันจะกล่าวถึงแค่บางส่วน
แม้ว่าจะไม่อธิบายอย่างละเอียด และโดยวิธี ถ้าคุณได้ความรู้สึกว่า fault tolerant quantum computing
ซับซ้อนและมีรายละเอียดมากมายที่ต้องกังวล นั่นก็เข้าใจได้เพราะมันเป็นเช่นนั้นจริงๆ มีส่วนเคลื่อนไหวหลายอย่าง
ที่นี่และเจตนาของฉันในบทเรียนนี้ไม่ใช่อธิบายรายละเอียดทั้งหมด แต่เพียงให้คุณเข้าใจพื้นฐานว่าทุกอย่าง
ทำงานอย่างไร วิธีหนึ่งสำหรับ fault tolerant quantum error correction เรียกว่า Shor error correction ตั้งชื่อตาม Peter
Shor ผู้เสนอวิธีนี้เป็นคนแรก แนวคิดคือทำ syndrome measurement แต่ละครั้งโดยใช้สิ่งที่เรียกว่า cat state
ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งเดียวกับ GHZ state เมื่อเรามีสาม qubits แต่สามารถ generalize ไปยังจำนวน qubits ใดก็ได้ที่ match กับ weight ของ stabilizer
generator ที่เราตั้งใจวัด โดยเฉพาะ circuit ที่แสดงที่นี่ทำงานสำหรับการวัด stabilizer generator และสามารถ
แสดงได้ว่าวิธีนี้ไม่ทำให้ข้อผิดพลาดแพร่กระจายภายใน code block
สิ่งนี้จำเป็นต้องสร้าง cat state เอง และเพื่อให้มันทำงานได้อย่างน่าเชื่อถือในการมีข้อผิดพลาดและ gates ที่อาจมีข้อบกพร่อง วิธีนี้จริงๆ แล้ว
ต้องการให้เราทำ circuits แบบนี้ซ้ำๆ และทำการอนุมานเกี่ยวกับตำแหน่งที่ข้อผิดพลาดต่างๆ อาจเกิดขึ้นระหว่าง
กระบวนการ วิธีทางเลือกเรียกว่า Steane error correction ซึ่งเสนอครั้งแรกโดย Andrew Steane และ
วิธีนี้ทำงานแตกต่างกันและทำงานได้เฉพาะกับ CSS codes เท่านั้น
ในวิธีนี้เราไม่ได้ทำการวัด syndrome บน quantum states ที่เข้ารหัสจริงๆ ใน
circuit ที่เรากำลังรัน แต่แทนที่เราจงใจแพร่กระจายข้อผิดพลาดไปยัง workspace system
และวัด system นั้นและตรวจจับข้อผิดพลาดแบบ classical รูปที่แสดงที่นี่แสดงวิธีทำสิ่งนี้สำหรับ X errors ซึ่งในกรณีนี้ workspace
qubits ถูก set ไว้เริ่มต้นเป็นการเข้ารหัสของ plus state ดังนั้นนี่พื้นฐานแล้วคือ
การนำ CNOT gate แบบ transversal มาใช้ซึ่งควรจะไม่ทำอะไร เพราะ target อยู่ใน plus state แต่ถ้า
มี X errors ใน qubits บน มันจะแพร่กระจายลงไปยัง system ล่างและจะถูกตรวจจับ ยังมีวิธีที่คล้ายกันในการตรวจจับ Z errors
ซึ่งไม่แสดงที่นี่ ยังมีวิธีที่เกี่ยวข้องที่เรียกว่า Knill error correction เสนอครั้งแรกโดย Manny Knill
และมันอิงจาก teleportation แทนที่จะเป็น transversal CNOT ซึ่งช่วยให้มันทำงานกับ arbitrary stabilizer
codes ไม่ใช่แค่ CSS codes
สิ่งสุดท้ายที่ฉันจะพูดถึงในบทเรียนนี้คือ theorem สำคัญมากที่เรียกว่า threshold theorem นี่คือ statement ที่ค่อนข้าง informal
ของ theorem มันบอกว่าถ้าเรามี quantum circuit ใดๆ ที่มี n gates โดยที่ n สามารถใหญ่เท่าที่ต้องการ
มันเป็นไปได้ที่จะนำ circuit นั้นไปใช้ด้วยความแม่นยำสูงโดยใช้ noisy quantum circuit ตราบเท่าที่ระดับของ noise
ต่ำกว่า threshold value ที่แน่นอนซึ่งเป็นอิสระจาก n และยิ่งไปกว่านั้น มันไม่แพงเกินไปที่จะทำสิ่งนี้ใน
แง่ที่ว่าขนาดของ noisy circuit ที่ต้องการอยู่ในลำดับของ n คูณ constant power ของ logarithm ของ
n การระบุ theorem อย่างเป็นทางการมากขึ้นต้องการการระบุ noise model อย่างเฉพาะเจาะจง ซึ่งฉันจะไม่ทำในบทเรียนนี้
มันสามารถพิสูจน์ได้สำหรับ independent stochastic noise model ที่ฉันกล่าวถึงก่อนหน้านี้ที่ข้อผิดพลาดเกิดขึ้น
อย่างอิสระที่แต่ละตำแหน่งที่เป็นไปได้ใน circuit ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นที่เล็กกว่า threshold value นี้อย่างเคร่งครัด แต่มันยังสามารถ
พิสูจน์ได้สำหรับ noise models ที่ general มากขึ้นที่อาจมีความสัมพันธ์ระหว่างข้อผิดพลาด ตอนนี้ นี่คือ theoretical
result และวิธีทั่วไปที่มันถูกพิสูจน์ไม่จำเป็นต้องแปลงเป็นสิ่งที่เราจะทำจริงๆ ในทางปฏิบัติ แต่มันก็ยังคงเป็น
theorem สำคัญมากในทางปฏิบัติ และเหตุผลสำหรับสิ่งนี้คือมันพื้นฐานแล้วบอกว่าไม่มีอุปสรรคพื้นฐานในการทำ
quantum computations โดยใช้ components ที่มีสัญญาณรบกวน
ตราบเท่าที่ error rate สำหรับ components เหล่านี้ต่ำกว่า threshold value นี้ พวกมันสามารถใช้สร้าง reliable quantum circuits ที่มีขนาดตามที่ต้องการ
อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการพูดถึงมันคือถ้า theorem ไม่เป็นจริง มันยากที่จะจินตนาการว่าการคำนวณควอนตัมขนาดใหญ่
จะเป็นความจริงได้ มีรายละเอียดทางเทคนิคมากมายที่เกี่ยวข้องใน formal proofs ของ theorem นี้ ซึ่งฉันจะไม่พยายาม
สื่อสาร แต่ฉันจะพยายามอธิบายแนวคิดพื้นฐานในระดับสูง และฉันจะพยายาม connect แนวคิดพื้นฐาน
แบบ loose กับสิ่งที่เราอาจคาดหวังให้เกิดขึ้นในทางปฏิบัติ ดังนั้นสมมติว่านี่คือ circuit ของเรา มันเป็น circuit เดิมที่
เราพูดถึงตลอดบทเรียนทั้งหมด แต่อีกครั้ง เราสามารถจินตนาการว่า circuit ของเราใหญ่และซับซ้อนกว่านี้มาก เราต้องการ
นำ circuit นี้มาใช้ แต่ components ทั้งหมดของเรามี noise และสมมติว่าเราใช้ independent stochastic noise
model เพื่อความเรียบง่าย มีความน่าจะเป็น P ที่ข้อผิดพลาดเกิดขึ้นอย่างอิสระที่แต่ละตำแหน่งที่เป็นไปได้
ถ้า circuit ใหญ่กว่า reciprocal ของ P นี้อย่างมีนัยสำคัญ เราก็มั่นใจได้ว่า
การนำมาใช้โดยตรงจะไม่ทำงานถูกต้อง ดังนั้นเราผ่านกระบวนการทั้งหมดของการนำ circuit ไปใช้
แบบ fault tolerant ตามที่ฉันพูดถึงจนถึงจุดนี้ในบทเรียน และเราถามตัวเองว่าคำถามที่ฉันเสนอก่อนหน้านี้ ซึ่งคือเรากำลังทำให้สิ่งต่างๆ
ดีขึ้นหรือแย่ลง ถ้าความน่าจะเป็น P ที่แสดงความน่าจะเป็นข้อผิดพลาดสำหรับ components ของเราแต่ละตัวใหญ่เกินไป
สิ่งนี้ก็จะไม่ช่วย เหมือนกับที่ 9 qubit Shore code ไม่ช่วยถ้าความน่าจะเป็นข้อผิดพลาดสูงกว่าประมาณ 3 และ 3/4 เปอร์เซ็นต์
โดยเฉพาะ เราทำให้ circuit ใหญ่ขึ้นแล้ว ดังนั้นมีตำแหน่งมากมายที่ข้อผิดพลาดอาจโจมตีได้
อย่างไรก็ตาม ถ้า P เล็กพอ สิ่งนี้จะช่วยได้ และสิ่งที่เราจะทำอย่างมีประสิทธิผลคือลด error
probability สำหรับการคำนวณแบบ logical ที่เรากำลังทำ ดังนั้นลองคิดเกี่ยวกับสิ่งนี้ใน
รายละเอียดเพิ่มขึ้นเล็กน้อย และเพื่อเห็นแนวคิดหลักในการตั้งค่าที่ง่ายที่สุดเท่าที่จะเป็นไปได้ สมมติว่าเราใช้ 7 qubit Steane code สำหรับ error
correction ซึ่งช่วยให้แก้ไขข้อผิดพลาดได้ไม่เกินหนึ่งตัวต่อ code block ดังนั้นเพื่อให้ logical error
เกิดขึ้นใน circuit ต้นฉบับ เราจะต้องมีข้อผิดพลาดอย่างน้อยสองตัวที่ตกอยู่ใน code block เดียวกันสำหรับ fault
tolerant implementation ของเรา
โดยคำนึงว่ามีวิธีต่างๆ มากมายในการมีข้อผิดพลาดสองตัวหรือมากกว่าใน code block เดียวกัน สามารถแย้งได้ว่าความน่าจะเป็นของ logical
error ที่แต่ละตำแหน่งใน circuit ต้นฉบับน้อยที่สุด C คูณ P กำลังสอง ที่ C คือตัวเลขที่ขึ้นอยู่กับโค้ดและ
gadgets ที่เราใช้ แต่ที่สำคัญคือมันไม่ขึ้นอยู่กับขนาดของ circuit ต้นฉบับ
ดังนั้นถ้า P เล็กกว่า reciprocal ของ C ซึ่งคือตัวเลขที่เราสามารถใช้เป็น threshold value เราก็
ได้ error ที่ลดลง ดังนั้นงานหนักของเราในการนำ circuit ไปใช้แบบ fault tolerant กำลังให้ผล
อย่างไรก็ตาม error rate ใหม่นี้อาจยังสูงเกินไปสำหรับ circuit ทั้งหมดในการทำงานถูกต้อง ดังนั้นเราต้อง
ทำมากขึ้น ในทางปฏิบัติสิ่งที่เป็นธรรมชาติที่จะทำในจุดนี้คือเลือกโค้ดที่ดีกว่าและ gadgets ที่ดีกว่าเพื่อลด error
rate ลงสู่จุดที่การนำมาใช้น่าจะทำงานได้
ในแง่ทฤษฎี วิธีง่ายๆ ในการแย้งว่าสิ่งนี้เป็นไปได้คือการ concatenate กล่าวคือเรา
คิดเกี่ยวกับการนำ fault tolerant ของ circuit ต้นฉบับเป็น logical circuit ใหม่ และจากนั้นเรานำมันไปใช้แบบ fault
tolerant แล้วเราทำสิ่งนี้ซ้ำๆ เท่าที่ต้องการ และปรากฏว่าสิ่งนี้ลด error
อย่างรวดเร็วมาก และนั่นคือวิธีที่ threshold theorem มักถูกพิสูจน์บนกระดาษ
ฉันจะให้ความคิดคร่าวๆ ว่า error rate ลดลงอย่างไร โดยละเว้นรายละเอียดทางเทคนิคมากมายที่จำเป็นในการ
พิสูจน์อย่างเป็นทางการ เราเริ่มด้วยความน่าจะเป็นข้อผิดพลาด P สำหรับ components ต้นฉบับของเรา และถ้าเรานำ
circuit ไปใช้แบบ fault tolerant error ลดลงด้วยปัจจัย C คูณ P ถ้าเราจากนั้นถือว่า fault tolerant
implementation ของเราเป็น logical circuit และนำไปใช้แบบ fault tolerant เราได้ error rate ที่ลดลงในลักษณะคล้ายกัน แต่
ถ้าเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ effective error rate สำหรับ circuit ต้นฉบับ เราพบว่ามันลดลงมากขึ้นอีกเพราะตอนนี้
เรากำลังแทนที่ error rate P ด้วย C คูณ P กำลังสอง เพราะนั่นคือ effective error rate หลัง first level fault
tolerant implementation โดยเฉพาะหลังจากทำ algebra เพียงเล็กน้อย เราพบว่า error ลดลงเป็น CP
กำลังสาม คูณ P และถ้าเราทำอีกครั้ง เรามี error rate CP กำลังเจ็ด คูณ P และถ้า
เราทำสิ่งนี้ต่อไปรวม K levels สิ่งที่เราพบคือ error หดตัว doubly exponentially ใน K ดังนั้น
เราไม่ต้องทำสิ่งนี้มากครั้งเพื่อทำให้ error rate เล็กมากๆ
ในขณะเดียวกัน circuits กำลังเติบโตขึ้นในขนาด แต่ขนาดเพิ่มขึ้นแค่ singly exponentially ใน K เพราะกับแต่ละ
level ของ fault tolerance ขนาดของ circuit ของเราเติบโตด้วยปัจจัยสูงสุดที่ถูกกำหนดโดยขนาดสูงสุดของ
gadgets ของเรา และเมื่อทุกอย่างรวมเข้าด้วยกันและตัวเลือกที่เหมาะสมสำหรับจำนวน
levels ของ concatenation ถูกสร้าง เราได้ threshold theorem แต่อย่างที่ฉันแนะนำแล้ว มีรายละเอียดมากมายที่จำเป็นเพื่อทำให้สิ่งนี้เป็นทางการ ดังนั้น
threshold value นี้ในความเป็นจริงคืออะไร ก็ขึ้นอยู่กับโค้ดและบน gadgets ที่เรา
ใช้ สำหรับ Steane code พร้อมกับ magic state distillation มันเล็กน้อยมากและน่าจะไม่สามารถทำได้ใน
ทางปฏิบัติ แต่โดยใช้ surface codes และ gadgets ล่าสุด มันถูกประเมินว่าประมาณ 1% ซึ่งไม่
เลวร้าย และเมื่อโค้ดและวิธีใหม่ถูกค้นพบ เราสามารถคาดหวังได้อย่างสมเหตุสมผลว่ามันจะเพิ่มขึ้น ในขณะเดียวกัน
ระดับของ noise ใน components ที่เราสร้างจะลดลง การไปถึงจุดที่
การคำนวณควอนตัมขนาดใหญ่สามารถนำมาใช้แบบ fault tolerant จะไม่ง่ายและจะไม่เกิดขึ้นในชั่วข้ามคืน
แต่ theorem นี้พร้อมกับความก้าวหน้าใน quantum codes และ quantum hardware ที่เราเป็นพยานจนถึงตอนนี้
ให้ความมั่นใจแก่เราที่ต้องการเพื่อผลักดันต่อไปเพื่อไปถึงเป้าหมายสูงสุดของการสร้าง
large-scale fault tolerant quantum computer และนั่นคือจุดสิ้นสุดของบทเรียนและจุดสิ้นสุดของซีรีส์ ฉัน
หวังจริงๆ ว่าคุณเห็นคุณค่าในซีรีส์นี้ และถ้าเป็นเช่นนั้น กรุณาพิจารณาแนะนำให้เพื่อนร่วมงานหรือเพื่อน
นอกจากนี้ อย่าลืมดู IBM Quantum Learning สำหรับ courses และ tutorials เพิ่มเติม และ subscribe ช่อง Qiskit
YouTube ถ้ายังไม่ได้ทำ เพื่อติดตามการ releases เนื้อหาในอนาคตของเรา ขอบคุณสำหรับ
การรับชม